ther one
of you's had a chance
to hold this weapon yet,
but I want to show you
a couple of details
about this weapon.
This is a very rare weapon
for even our league.
With over 500 members,
there's only two of these
in the league.
That is a massive,
hefty weapon.
This -- What this essentially
is, is a huge cleaver.
There's varieties of this
all through the medieval period.
This one is the so-called
Maciejowski chopper.
It's from, uh,
the Morgan Crusader Bible,
where we see it depicted.
You see this ripping through
mail armor -- chain mail armor.
But even on plate,
it's devastating.
What it lacks
in maneuverability,
it more than makes up for
in sheer brutal hitting power.
I think the technical term
for that, John, is holy [bleep]
Yeah.
It's not a weapon that uses
a lot of finesse.
Again, it's not
an elegant weapon.
It's a pretty brutal,
straightforward, you know,
diagonal hit,
vertical hit.
There's not a lot of play
with it.
You're not gonna see
a lot of warding
and covering and binding.
You're not gonna see
a lot of parrying.
You're just gonna see
smash, smash, smash.
You know, one of the scenes
in the Maciejowski Bible
is a warrior --
a knight, actually --
using this weapon and cleaving
somebody from the neck
all the way down to the wet --
the waist.
Mm-hmm.
It's a very bloody depiction
in that bible.
Everything's
spilling out.
I mean, you can just feel
the power in your hands
with this thing --
like the size of it.
Now, the -- the grooves,
or fullers --
uh, they're there for one
reason and one reason only
on any bladed weapon --
to reduce its weight.
That's their
sole purpose --
to reduce weight and create
a structural strength
to it, like an I-beam.
-Well, you can feel the weight.
You can feel the weight
at the top of the sword,
at the -- the peak.
-Yeah.
So it's an inelegant weapon,
but it is a brutal cleaver
that's going to chop,
hack, cleave into targets.